Russian forces launched new deadly
strikes in Ukrainian cities including Za
parisia where Kremlin staged voting is
underway today marks the second day that
people in russian-occupied regions are
voting on whether to become part of
Russia President Biden and other world
leaders have dismissed the referendum
calling it illegitimate the White House
says it's prepared to impose more
sanctions on Russia if President
Vladimir Putin carries out threats to
Annex more Ukrainian territory Deborah
patta is in key the Ukrainian Capital
with the latest Deborah good morning
good morning Russia is holding
referendums in four occupied territories
in Ukraine in order to push through a
vote to Annex these regions the five-day
process began yesterday and has been
widely condemned in the west as a sham
virtually destroyed by Russian
bombardment and abandoned by residents
who managed to escape before the Kremlin
took control it is in occupied cities
like these that elections slammed as
illegal by the West are taking place
Ivan federov the exiled mayor of now
occupied militar Paul said Ukrainian
citizens are being held hostage forced
to vote under Russia's watchful eye it's
impossible to make referendum in other
cities of temporary occupied territory
nobody wants to collaborate
it opens up a dangerous new phase in
this wall there are fears Vladimir Putin
could use it as a pretext to escalate
the conflict claiming an attack on newly
annexed territories is an attack on
Russia
Britain's been pushed into a corner
after his troops suffered crushing
losses in herkiv this past week of the
anti-threatening to unleash nuclear
weapons and announced a call-up for
military reservists that has not gone
down well at home there's been a
panicked Exodus of Russians trying to
escape conscription as young men try to
dodge the draft like 27 year old Nikita
he's crazy I am just for freedom
Russia from Putin in the Far East of
Russia another long line new conscripts
boarding military planes call our papers
were handed out within hours of Putin's
announcement giving citizens no time to
say a proper goodbye only tearful
farewells and frantic Embraces
nobody is holding their breath in
suspense about the referendum results a
similar vote in 2014 led to the
annexation of Crimea the hastily
organized elections take place along the
front lines of the war and are seen by
the White House as a sign of Putin's
weakness for CBS Saturday morning
Deborah Potter kiv Ukraine